je reviens un peu sur le week-end des
chroniqueurs 1 je vous le dis déjà kenny
vous vous avez partout sur les réseaux
en ce week-end ah bon alors il était à
marrakech celle ci avec virginie la
styliste gini la styliste que vous
connaissez alors un moment vous voit
mettre l'ambiance
et attention c'est très gênant regarder
ce que je vais choisir en fonction de ça
qui va faire une interro surprise mais
c'est quoi
[Musique]
et il y avait lavé géraldine maillet cas
passés at est également à marrakech
apparemment je vous le dise il y avait
tous ces gens là tmp c'est que bien sûr
ce séjour était gratuit 1 là je connais
un petit peu les personnes minces et
vous est-ce que vous avez payé
oui beaucoup de choses allaient aller
chez toi à palomba par l'eau minérale a
wheel ou tel site vous les repas lopez
et l'hôtel l'hôtesse que vous avez payé
l'hôtel oui l'autre l'hôtel el moreno
non mais kelly non mais dites la bagarre
dans un hôtel annoncé on connaît bien à
la laminé alors moi aussi je connais
bien les pc en bas je paye quand même le
rocher
est-ce que vous avez payé l'hôtel non
mais tu es invité par là la meilleure
amie de bernard montiel si vous avez
payé l'avion
ah oui mais par contre bah oui tu y vas
juré le abba bien sûr c'est vous qui les
a invités oui oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
valérie voir j'étais sur instagram et ce
week end vous avez posté des trucs un
peu un peu ringard on allait garder
beinheim ah oui mais naïma là c'est
l'été dans mon corps
la taille c'est génial c'est simplement
goût il journée à tous je vous embrasse
message m
qu'est ce qu'un genevois 3400 j'aime
quand 3400 j'aimerais comme ça y'a comme
quoi y'a des gens très gentils mois et
jean-michel n'avait rien envoyé à la
rédaction vous avez aimé quoi vous allez
travailler a malheureusement je joue là
vous j'ai données transmis un vie ça m'a
fichu du travail elle a le bac dans
trois semaines on a fait un week-end
boulot pour réviser la géo l'histoire
les lada et dont l'algérie la géographie
un accord illustre jean a bossé comme
des oufs d'affaires de la division vous
êtes bonjour vous ajouterez très bon
boulot reste en malaisie mais alors là
la capitaine de la capitale de l'afrique
du sud
bah oui johannesburg nom de théorie non
non c'est quoi pas dit que c'est le cas
alors il est venu passer des vacances il
à l'état du jeu mais ce boom énorme
c'est comme ces camps l'australie la
capitale économique et la capitale
politique enfin c'est trop compliqué
pour le sida y voir vous ne vous
tromperez pas que l'international